[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
c'est l'un des débats qui fait
l'actualité depuis quelques jours la
société de vigilance est elle un moyen
efficace de lutter contre la
radicalisation
le président de la république vient
d'appeler les français à la mobilisation
contre l'islam radical lors de l'hommage
aux quatre victimes du tueur radicaliser
de la préfecture de police de paris
emmanuel macron appelé les français à
construire une société de vigilance pour
combattre dit il l'hydre islamiste
est ce un aveu de faiblesse de nos
services de renseignement et de sécurité
une invitation à plus de solidarité
entre les citoyens ou au contraire à la
dénonciation
comment vivre en sécurité et en même
temps qu'elle se quelle société voulons
pour l'avenir
on en débat avec mes invités en direct
ce matin raphaël gauvin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marche
de saône et loire vous avez été
rapporteur de la loi sur la sécurité
intérieure et vous êtes actuellement
membre de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur justement cet attentat
de la préfecture de police de paris
hamid el hassouni bonjour bonjour vous
êtes conseiller départemental ps de
côte-d'or et adjoint au maire de dijon
jacques richard des ti bonjour vous êtes
vice-président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté paul garrigues
bonjour vous êtes président de la
section de dijon de la ligue des droits
de l'homme avec des responsabilités
également de dans cette ligue des droits
de l'homme au niveau national merci à
tous les cas d'avoir accepté cette
invitation vous qui nous regarde et vous
pouvez bien sûr commenter cette émission
en direct avec le hashtag dean paul
bourgogne alors j'ai envie de vous
demander aux uns et aux autres un
premier tour de table
quand vous avez entendu emmanuel macron
par les deux sociétés de vigilance
qu'est ce que vous vous êtes dit qu'est
ce que ça vous évoque
raphaël commun mais je pense que c'était
une nécessité face à hauts risques
terroristes qu on sait depuis quelques
années notamment depuis la les attentats
du bataclan qui a un risque mais que ce
que les services de sécurité nous dise
un risque endogène au sein de la société
française et donc il faut faire preuve
de vigilance alors après c'est on va en
débattre
ça va être l'objet du débat il va il
faut trouver un équilibre parce que il
ya un risque de stigmatisation en et en
même temps il faut faire preuve de
vigilance la première réaction hamid el
hassouni vous avez réagi même sur les
réseaux sociaux
exactement d'abord je tiens à rendre
hommage aux victimes des attentats
odieux et une pensée émue aux familles
dont la vie la vie a basculé du jour au
lendemain suite à ces drames
c'est vrai quand on analyse le discours
du président la république on retient
des expressions qui frappe les esprits
lyderic islamique et la suite et de
vigilance je pense que au delà du
discours il faut aussi apporter des
réponses pragmatiques
sans pointer du doigt à venir une partie
de la communauté nationale c'est ce que
j'ai reproché par le biais des réseaux
sociaux présentent la république qui
affiche tout simplement un aveu de
faiblesse et il le démontre par la faire
la preuve que le problème est éminemment
complexe et mais qu'il faut apporter des
réponses collectives sans mettre au ban
de la société une partie de la
population française jacques richard
betty alors effectivement moins
effectifs ont rapporté effectivement des
réponses collectives et la vigilance est
une des réponses collectives devraient
remettre en perspective en sur plusieurs
décennies c'est de 186 morts on voit
tous les jours des services publics qui
partent comme les services régaliens de
l'état que ce soit la police ou la
gendarmerie donc effectivement on
appelle les citoyens à être vigilants
alors effectivement c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être par défaut et je pense
que le citoyen doit être vigilant s'il
veut s'il veut faire respecter son calme
c'est sa manière de vivre et sa sécurité
ça me paraît très important l'image fait
réagir il y avait évidemment d'abord
l'émotion et des tragédies ensuite au
sud du caire des questionnements 1
et quand on a vu les premières
interprétations qui ont été faites je
pense notamment monsieur blanc caire l'a
beaucoup d'inquiétude un risque de tout
mélanger le rôle de vigilance qui doit
être celui des services de l'état de la
police de la justice
oui chacun son métier
alors évidemment chaque citoyen par une
perdrix gilles ans on rame à gages
accompagnerait le signaler
mais quand la vigilance les exemples qui
ont été données laissent un peu crainte
qu'on aille sur une société de délation
on va y venir aux exemples évidemment
mais il faut le dire on fait un peu
frémir certains exemples donnés c'est
une première en quelque sorte lors de
l'hommage mardi 8 octobre aux quatre
fonctionnaires de la préfecture de
police de paris
le président a donc appelé à une société
de vigilance je vous propose de
l'écouter mais je veux aussi vous le
dire avec force aujourd'hui les
institutions seules ne suffiront pas
l'administration seul et tous les
services de l'état ne saurait venir à
bout de l'hydre islamiste
non c'est la nation toute entière qui
doit s'unir se mobilisent et agir nous
ne l'emporteront que si notre pays qui
est venu à bout de temps étant des
preuves dans l'histoire se lève pour
lutter contre cet islamisme souterrain
qui corrompt les enfants de france une
société de vigilance
voilà ce qu'il nous revient de bâtir la
vigilance et non le soupçon qui corrode
la vigilance l' écoute attentif de
l'autre
l'éveil raisonnable des consciences
alors il ya beaucoup de choses dans ce
discours d' emmanuel macron et dans cet
extrait même il ya beaucoup d'éléments à
prendre en compte raphaël gauvin
manquant jean todt président de la
république si je suis membre des
services de renseignement de police je
me dis on doit pas faire bien notre
travail parce que finalement il faut que
tout le monde le fasse non pas du tout
il a bien dit que ça venait par des
arguments c'est pas du tout un désaveu
qui venait en complément
après moi je vous donner des exemples
très concrets sur la société du silence
ce qui se passe depuis 2015 et ce qu'il
faut sans doute développé par exemple en
saône et loire ce qui se passe le préfet
tous les mois il convoque la totalité
des services de l'état des associations
etc etc
dans l'ensemble du département ça se
fait dans le département mais aussi au
niveau de l'arrondissement
et du sous-préfet et ça leur permet de
faire remonter les les informations donc
qui concerne il ya aussi les services de
renseignement mais plus largement encore
une fois les associations et on remonte
les informations qui concernent les des
risques de dérives ou de radicalisation
etc et se permettent de donner de
l'information de croiser les
informations et après ce sont les
services de renseignement c'est pas les
citoyens qui vont procéder à la
vérification etc sont les services de
renseignement qui vont travailler
quelque chose qui existe en saône et
loire depuis 2015 qui avait été mis en
place par le préfet avant et qu'il faut
sans doute généralisé
il ya un problème aussi dans le discours
d' emmanuel macron c'est con on définit
pas bien les choses
qu'est ce qu'une société de vigilance et
puis qu'est ce que vraiment la
radicalisation à quel moment et comment
ça calmement et termine alors la
radicalisation ne viendra dans un moment
mais elle société de vigilance c'est
quoi hamid el hassouni près dans la
démagogie le risque zéro n'existe pas
néanmoins faire appel aux citoyens pour
essayer de d'identifier de repérer on
veut dire les signes avant-coureurs de
la radicalisation en citant quelques
exemples qui nous paraissent un peu
farfelue quand on a un peu de hauteur de
vue c'est dire à un moment donné à voir
une tache sur le front à les mesurer la
taille de la barre de son voisin où est
lentement le vol serait potentiellement
risque de radicalisation
je pense qu'à un moment donné il ne faut
pas que les autorités se défausse et
transferts 7,17 compétences cette
délégation ce pouvoir régalien aux
citoyens et puis nous on est informé les
citoyens mais surtout le risque c'est
d'ouvrir la boîte de pandore ccc un
moment donné c'est de basculer dans delà
de la dénonciation abusive et c'est
l'homme à un moment donné
la fissure entre les différents pans de
la population risque d'éclater jacques
richard s'il vous plaît voilà je tiens à
resituer encore une fois 2 186 morts
je pense aux victimes je pense aux
parents je pense aux veuves
je pense aux parents qui ont perdu leurs
enfants s'ils voulaient bien mes
citoyens comment nous étions simplement
moi je vais vous donner un exemple qui
marchent que ça va bien bon c'est pas
que je sais faire mais je sais que dans
les petites communes
je suis merde aussi d'une petite commune
je sais gré on a ce qu'on appelle les
citoyens vigilants récemment mais des
pancartes dans les communes pour le
voisinage et compagnie donc voilà si si
vous si vous si vous trouvez que votre
voix
1 et d'attitudes quelquefois eh bien
vous ne dénoncez vous dénoncez pas je
veux dire vous ne dénoncez pas mais
simple simplement vous vous indiquer aux
services de police ou de gendarmerie qui
est un problème voyez une voiture
suspecte passer dans la rue je veux dire
c'est pas ça c'est le travail de la
police et des services de renseignement
mais le sait c'est un travail conjoint
c'est un travail du des services de
police et je le savais que ce n'était
pas le cas c'était le cas je vous le dis
vous donner un exemple du citoyen
vigilant et l'exemple du shit citoyens
vigilants je pense que c'est un bon
exemple savent c'est alors c'est quelque
chose qui existe pourtant sur plateau
que la reine à vide en marche sont un
peu d'accord sur certains sujets non
mais c'est intéressant
non mais le les citoyens vigilants si
vous avez quelque chose qui existe
depuis 2010 qui est mis en place sous
sarkozy est ce que hollande aussi qui a
été développée et généralisée dans
l'ensemble et c'est quelque chose qui
marche très bien et on n'est pas du tout
tomber dans la délation les risques à
l'origine posait question est en réalité
ça a été très très bien gérée par les
services de gendarmerie
quelque chose qui n existent notamment
pour les vols qui pouvait avoir lieu
pendant la course
c'est quelque chose qui marche très très
bien et qui vient non pas se substituer
aux forces de police mais qui vient en
complément
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il y ait un jeu
qu'on appelle alors à c'est un terme un
peu technique puisqu'il ya un continuum
de sécurité entre les voisins vigilants
les services de gendarmerie les services
après deux enquêtes etc
c'est qui est ce continuum de sécurité
après je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
être fallu aussi vigilants dans les deux
sens c'est à dire qu'il faut faire il
faut être également vigilant face au
risque de stigmatisation ni aux dérives
etc et c'est pour ça que l'exemple de
vous deux voisins vigilants des services
est assez bon parce que l'équilibré a
fallu a été trouvé on a beaucoup de
choses à beaucoup de choses à dire je le
dirai quand on dira qu'on peut repérer
une voiture suspecte
moi je guette sur mon balcon tous les
jours mais je pas repéré une voiture
suspecte mais monsieur vous me laisser
finir s'il vous plaît vous les batteries
culation correspond pas à vous
reconnaissez perçoit bas
quand il joue là bas non les numéros
nous regarde chacun se venger mais
heureusement parce qu'on aurait beaucoup
mais ceci dit c'est comme ça dit comme
ça tout en temps mais c'est comme suc a
été donné comme exemple est assez
affolant
parce que c'est sous le coup de
l'émotion et du coup ça passe je vais
dire est que l'émotion vous l'avez tous
dit l'émotion était terrible on a vu ces
images de cercueils etc et du coup on se
dit eh oui il faut prendre il faut
prendre des mesures immédiatement quoi
c'est je crois que en matière quand même
parce qu'on a des matières de sécurité
de liberté qui sont complexes en matière
de sécurité liberté je suis pas sûr que
l'émotion soit toujours bonne
conseillère et les exemples ont été
donnés sont assez affolant
sauf à dire que il faudrait que je
dénonce le ce cas staner pour sa barbe
monsieur sarkozy parce qu'il boit pas
d'alcool à la caricature c'est pas de la
caricature c'est les exemples qui ont
été données l'ont fait alors j'ai de la
chance elle a été touchée dans votre
famille dans votre coeur vous demande
monsieur voilà bon sujet montrent
ensuite vous éviter d'interrompre les
gens tapent à éviter les caricatures a
essayé de parler sur l'officiel sur le
parce que sur le fond et ensuite c'est
ce qui est quand même le gros mélange
dangereux qu'on sente et je pense là
dessus que mise l'éducation nationale
plus que d'autres a franchi la ligne
on l'a vu aussi aux diversités comtois
son avis c'est un mélange entre ce
qu'est une base quand même de la liberté
de la laïcité en france c'est la liberté
religieuse c'est la base de la licité
fine des trois bases la liberté de
conscience et la liberté religieuse dans
toute religion ou prou toute absence de
religion et nous ce qu'on craint
d'ensemble discours qu'on entend
si l'action des musulmans c'est qu'on
mélange le droit absolu la liberté
religieuse avec le terrorisme et en plus
on prend part et je crois que c'est le
meilleur service à rendre au terrorisme
que de tout mélanger le risque il est là
il est le risque c'est la stigmatisation
d'une partie de notre de notre
population et donc la vigilance
elle doit être de des deux côtés face à
cette dérive là mais fasse aussi il faut
regarder la réalité en face il y a un on
est aujourd'hui notre pays aujourd'hui
même ce qui n'est pas engagé nous nous
sommes en guerre
face à ce risque c'est qu'elle risque
islamiste c'est quelque chose
durée on ne va pas durer une semaine ou
quelques mois c'est quelque chose qui va
durer des années voire une génération
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
preuve de vigilance par rapport à ça
aller la solution mais le problème de
canton quand on lit entre les lignes du
discours du président de la république
il ya quand même à dessein ou de façon
maladroite une confusion qui lance le
prob et qui stigmatise une partie de la
population mais abandonnée l'hydre
islamiste et et radicalisation c'est ça
vise pas non mais c'est une réalité
d'une dérive ou de woods de certains
terroristes qui se servent de l'islam
pour à des fins politiques
je pense que je pense que faire d'eux
semblait pas si mon nom mais l'état ne
doit pas avoir la main qui tremble
lorsqu'il s'agit d'être de frapper fort
contre ceux qui veulent semer la terreur
et créer le chaos hisser en france oui
mais qui se désistent elle sur la en
l'occurrence en règle générale on
s'aperçoit avec un peu de recul que ses
autres des gens qui se revendique d'une
religion mais qui sont loin de respecter
les préceptes de faire de l'argent
qu'ils ont qui relaie puis souvent on va
dire d'une hospitalisation dans un
hôpital psychiatrique plutôt que d'une
religion ou d'une religion sont vous la
faire alors le problème c'est que moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas vraiment senti ça dans
le jeu vous le dis honnêtement dans les
propos du président la république parce
que les termes étaient quand même bien
choisir est ce qu'il ya un risque quand
même est-ce que vous y faites attention
de stigmatisation des musulmans bien sûr
non mais surtout le risque mais vous
l'avez mais je vous rejoins parfaitement
le risque c'est que on perde les modérés
et qu' il bascule et au fait le jeu des
extrémistes
les extrémistes que je joue al rasul
nationale et les ce qu'on a le libre
l'idri samedi ils se nourrissent entre
eux et donc le risque pour nous vous
n'aimez sur l'axé on va vous donner à
voir juste derrière juste derrière le
risque c'est les modérés les musulmans
modérés bascule et que se radicalise et
se radicalise eux-mêmes et donc
évidemment que on est on est sur une
ligne de crête
mais il faut se rendre compte que il ya
ce risque il ya ce chiffre risque
terroriste cette menace endogène qui est
analysé qui datent pas de l'attentât de
la préfecture de police de paris
ce risque endogène on le connaît depuis
les attentats du bataclan donc ça fait
quatre ans maintenant quatre ans que on
s'arme et donc petit à petit et ce à
quoi
le président a appelé ses que celle
affaire de tous la sécurité je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de ce continuum de
sécurité celle affaire de tous
c'est pas seulement la sphère des des
services de sécurité c'est la sphère de
tous et donc il faut face à face hrx la
être vigilant et maîtresses et vigilants
on a beaucoup critiqué les maquereaux
nisme sur le fameux en même temps mais
là encore une fois on est face à une
ligue de créteil il faut faire du en
même temps face à lahore au risque
d'attentât lors à midi il n'y a pas de
garrigues et jacques chirac il faut
trouver le bon équilibre entre ni
angélisme ni état policier donc un
moment donné il ya eu des défaillances
il faut éventuellement tout remettre à
plat pour réactualiser redire les
méthodes de contrôle mais surtout faut
qu'il faudrait qu'au coeur du dispositif
de contrôle ce soit l'état avant tout à
un moment donné je rappelle une chose le
la loi prévoit qu'un citoyen lambda a
vocation à dire à dénoncer on va dire ce
voisin si il a l'intention de commettre
l'irréparable
c'est prévu par l'allemange après sur le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui un moment
donné le problème d'un discours c'est
qu'à un moment donné c'est il appelle à
l'unité de la nation
qu'on soit citoyens venus d'horizons
divers ou citoyens de longue date et en
même temps on a l'impression quand même
que les regards sont braqués sur une
partie de la communauté un moment
d'émission veut vraiment combattre mais
combattre définitivement et mettre un
terme justement à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui le dur de la préfecture de
paris était un citoyen français qui est
qui était en l'occurrence des dom tom
c'est pas quelqu'un venu d'ailleurs
j'arrête j'aimerais dire que depuis des
depuis de nombreuses années on a des
difficultés s'ils voulaient bien faut
pas que vous l'avez dit vous-même faut
pas que la main tremble à moment donné
il faut il faut arrêter de se cacher
derrière son petit doigt s'y mettre tous
les moyens pour faire respecter la
sécurité c'est ça c'est ça qui est
important
les gens ont besoin de sécurité c'est
cet extrémisme islamisme islamistes
pardon et c'est celui là dont on parle
en parle pas d'autre chose on ici autant
de cette table donc c'est celui ci qui
fait des morts c'est celui ci qui fait 2
186 morts s'ils voulaient bien
maintenant il faut prendre des
résolutions vous étaient encore massés
résolution renforçant les moyens des
services de renseignement vigilant
laure et ça fonctionne calgary oui oui
je crois quand même lorsque vous disiez
quelque chose qui me gêne un peu quand
vous dites il ya un risque que les
musulmans modérés contre écrit et je
crois que non je crois que l'immense
majorité est musulman ne tombera pas
dans l'extrémisme majorité et leur a
rappelé que les premières victimes quand
même du terrorisme islamiste sont des
musulmans bientôt dans le monde 1 y a
qu'à voir les kurdes comme on les lâche
aujourd'hui mais par contre le risque de
la stigmatisation c'est qu'une petite
minorité de gens qui sont mal dans leur
peau pour atteint d'autres raisons comme
dans d'autres époques ils ont pu se
laisser prendre dans notre idéologie
criminelle se laisse pas d'aujourd'hui
et je crois comme que le rôle des
citoyens et je pense qu'en plus d'une
pour une association comme la nôtre je
te souhaite aussi le rôle des politiques
laissons faire au service de
renseignement la justice leur métier
qu'est légitime mais notre loup c'est
comment semble-t-il travail et dans la
société pour avoir une société du vivre
ensemble une société où il n'y ait pas
de terreau pour pour le terrorisme
et je crois que le vrai rôle des
politiques en vue d'y associer tisser sa
égard un rôle alors central de la
justice et de la police qui à notre
raphaël gauvin vauréal jardin on craque
pour pascal est mouvante et les
résultats semblent en fait le risque de
basculement il est si on stigmatise trop
une partie de la population
on risque de perdre les modérés c'est ça
que je voulais vous dire c'est que si on
stigmatise une partie de la population
s'est modérée la risque de basculer dans
dans le radicalisme et puis juste sur
votre dernière crainte il ya force
restera toujours à l'état force restera
à la loi
il est hors de question hors de question
de créer en france des milices privées
certains peuvent être d'accord avec ça
mais je peux vous dire force restera
toujours à la loi a une à la république
reste alors à la loi à la rue blanche
s'emporte mobilisation quand lancers
francs 7 face à rafa un instant qu'en
pensent les français sont intéressants
selon une enquête menée par l'ifop et
publiée ce matin dans le journal du
dimanche vous propose de regarder 57 %
des français pensent que les citoyens
ont un rôle à jouer dans la détection et
le signalement des comportements de
radicalisation et 43 prend pour cent des
français pensent que c'est avant tout
aux forces de l'ordre et au service de
enseignement de détecter et de signaler
les comportements alors on voit que
c'est pas évident est-ce qu'il va
falloir former les français c'est à dire
c'est quoi un signe de radicalisation
comment est ce qu'on dénonce son petit
camarade
est-ce qu'il faut que les gens soient
éduqués à ça parce que sinon on peut
partir dans tous les sens à l'idée d'un
mois chez moi avoir un peu plus de
détails c'est un moment donné qu'on nous
communique on va dire le pedigree le
mode d'emploi est le portrait-robot d'un
voisin qui se radicalise
le problème c'est que c'est on revient
on a ouvert la boîte de pandore c'est un
fourre tout qu'on apporte des éléments
complémentaires en 10 ans éventuellement
il ya des risques de radicalisation mais
surtout passer par l'intermédiaire des
services de l'état dont c'est la
compétence premières ont dit d'autres
choses que ça je crois
le risque c'est pas que ça dérive si si
les services de renseignement et de
police ne soit pas derrière ne soient
pas arrivés ils sont ils sont derrière
ils sont derrière sont force pour
l'instant salle s'est pas encore écouté
ils sont forcément derrière on a on n'a
pas demandé on n'a pas demandé la
création enfin je pense pas que le
président de république a demandé à ce
que ce qu'on dénonce son voisin ou
qu'elle est d'aider des milices privées
qui soit créer simplement la vigilance
citoyenne et elle me paraît elle me
paraît trop cool et de souk ahras qui va
nous falloir un petit 9-6 mais non mais
quand même à dre la question d'abord
est-ce qu'il va falloir une petite
notice comme la note de la préfecture
interne de police de paris dont j'ai un
extrait ici pour trouver d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs personnes ont été
stoppés dans leur dans leur travail
parce que il y avait des signes de
radicalisation changements physiques et
vestimentaires alimentaires refus de
serrer la main au personnel féminin ou
rejet brutal des habitudes quotidiennes
un exemple concret très simplement
quelqu'un qui pratique à la mosquée tous
les vendredis qui voit que son voisin se
radicalise ou qui voit un prêche d'un
imam radicaliser qui dérape
cette personne-là est à même de faire un
signalement tout simplement tout
simplement c'est ça c'est du concret oui
mais parce qu'on doit voir quelqu'un qui
se radicalise charles vous voyez bien
que ça peut ça peut vouloir que
n'importe pas dans tout jeu je suis
croyant je suis musulman je suis au sein
d'une structure je vais prier tous les
tous les vendredi à la mosquée je vois
que mon voisin à des attitudes ou ou ne
veut pas serrer la main aux femmes ou ou
à des attitudes après un attentat comme
charlie se sentent de la préfecture de
police de paris vous cela vous dirait
juste quand on dit marie changements
physiques et vestimentaires alimentaires
refus de serrer la main au personnel
féminin
par exemple comme des choses qui va la
faire la préfecture de voirie et de les
laisser dans la ferme de la préfecture
de paris
il semble j semble se gauvin sera
certainement bien puisque moi bientôt
qu'ils aient eu des dérapages
inadmissibles la part d'un fonctionnaire
de police par exemple il semblerait on
me semblerait qu'il ait approuvé
publiquement des attentats là on peut se
dire là toutes les lignes rouges ont été
franchies changements d'habitudes
alimentaires
bah moi il se trouve que j'ai des
enfants je ressens devenu végétarien je
les ai pas dénoncer à la police
non mais le changement d'habitudes
alimentaires
voilà où n'importe qui aujourd'hui en
france qui est c'est sa liberté qui n'a
pratiqué pas de religion et qui décide
de pratiquer telle ou telle religion et
d'ailleurs et à d'autres religions à
condé interdits alimentaires
je vois pas en quoi c'est un problème et
yaya comme des choses nécessaires à la
ligne de crête et quand on a vu monsieur
blanc caire par l'ère des petits garçons
qui donnait pas la main aux fidji mais
non mais où on va surtout de la part des
remises et déjà on sait très bien que
quand alors l'année enfants dracula les
sens
il ya des choses oui qui sont dangereux
je trouve effectivement pas de me cible
et c'est clair la part d'un
fonctionnaire de pop en général et de
police en particulier de justifier des
attentes ailleurs dollar devenu citoyen
oui mais là et encore plus quand on est
jamais mieux dire et puis ce que vous
disiez sur des des choses qui peuvent
dire des prêches prendra comme une loi
puis deux fois n'est pas bien fait mais
qu'il est faux est bien fait et je
contrôle adéquat dans la loi française
aujourd hui des choses assez précises ya
des délits l'incitation à la haine
raciale est un délit d'incitation à la
haine cause de religion est un délit
l'incitation au meurtre est un délit et
je crois il faut en rester à sakal kaki
publiquement incitent à la haine incite
au meurtre est un délinquant oui
d'accord mais pour mais on saura si le
dollar s'il faut pour fonctionner
quelqu'un le dise ce monsieur calcium
pourrait être un citoyen lambda avait
tout à fait mais je vous dirais la ligue
des droits de l'homme non seulement
dénoncer le sommet apporter
régulièrement plainte
la ligue des droits l'homme a porté
plainte contre dieudonné a porté plainte
contre zemmour a fait condamner ces
individus pour incitation à la
et on n'a aucun problème s'il ya des
incitations à la haine droits de l'homme
a condamné à condamner des condamnés des
attentats islamistes est ce qu elle a
porté plainte contre des prêches
régulier dans les mosquées salafistes et
compagnie je ne crois pas à monsieur je
ne crois pas alors là les gallois de
mâcon et messieurs vous avez aussi sur
dijon vous avez en franche comté d des
prêches radical dans les mosquées j'ai
pas vu la ligue des droits de l'homme
alors répondez parce que vous êtes
d'abord sur les attentats bhl évidemment
les a condamnés sans nuance nous soyons
quand même sérieux unis et ya d'autres
crimes que tonnes de co2 condamne par un
je voudrais quand vous condamnerez les
milliers de morts en méditerranée de
l'europe fermé on pourra dire que vous
condamnez pas l'écrit c'est pas le débat
d'aujourd'hui mais un peu comme le dire
quand même nous prenons les sages
comment ça peut se mettre en ménage mais
si vous voulez pour nous si on est
saisie d'un appel à l'aide mais de qui
ils viennent les victimes
et si ça nous est si cette nature ou le
statut de permettre on pourra se porter
partie alors on est bientôt à la fin de
l'émission très rapidement raphael gobât
ça va se mettre en place comme ans parce
qu'on a l'impression que là on appelle
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un code de bonne
conduite de ses citoyens vigilants qui
vont y aura pas un code de bonne
conduite
je vous dis c'est quelque chose qui
existe déjà je vous ai donné l'exemple
rimer par exemple des voisins vigilants
vis la gendarmerie ce comité
mais si je n'en avais jamais le
réalisera d'élimination le québec est
nommé c'est quelque chose qu'il faut pas
comparer le terrorisme islamiste avec le
vol dans une maison fermée votre
vigilance
et puis les comédies drames de
radicalisation qui existe au sein des
départements au sein de certains
départements
c'est sans doute quelque chose qu'il
faut général est un renforcement quand
même des services de renseignement parce
qu'il va falloir accompagner déjà si ces
citoyens d'agir là il va faire les
achats longtemps répond lé les services
de renseignement en deux ans on est
passé de 1 un fonctionnaire à près de 4
donc voilà c'est un exemple très concret
et il ya une mobilisation des moyens de
l'état pour renforcer ses services et
hamid el hassouni qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour éviter que les choses
dérapent mais aussi éviter les attentats
terroristes
il faut déjà instauré des garde-fous
pour éviter que les plateaux
téléphoniques de l'état soient submergés
d'appels on va dire
je dérange beaucoup amusé ou moins
sérieux et un moment donné ce qui est
dommage c'est que dans la boîte à outils
justement pour essayer de tordre le cou
à ce titre islamique et aussi des
groupuscules d'extrême droite je
rappelle quand même qu'ils aimaient
réseau qui a été démantelé cette année
en juin donc qu'ils avaient l'intention
de poser des bombes dans des mosquées
si charles précisé donc un moment donné
moi ce que je veux c'est que certains
appelaient à l'unité de la nation on ne
peut pas exclure une part une part
importante de la population qui
représente je crois de mémoire à peu
près 10% la population donc vraiment de
nice il faut avancer collectivement et
ensemble sera le mot de la fin
exclure quiconque merci à tous d'avoir
accepté de débattre en direct ce matin
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
aujourd'hui dans un instant un point sur
l'actualité régionale avec elle a besoin
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]